16h45 sur public sénat
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec katia gilbert bourges
médias et dans l'actualité cette semaine
certains appellent cela une mauvaise
passe d'autres y verront un tournant du
quinquennat la sphère leonarda en tout
cas n'en finit pas d'empoisonner la vie
du gouvernement au coeur de ce débat
l'immigration manuel valls veut une
réforme du droit d'asile l'ump s'en
prend au droit du sol l'actualité
parlementaire c'est aussi la mise à
contribution des revenus de l'épargné
pour financer la protection sociale pap
est les assurances vie seront tous taxés
à 15 5% les députés ont voté l'article
de loi sous les huées de la droite qui
dénoncent une mesure inconstitutionnelle
cette semaine de plus de l'hebdo vous
fera découvrir les premières images du
film le cinquième pouvoir c'est
l'histoire de la naissance de ce site
internet wikileaks et de son fondateur
julian assange
ou comment les lanceurs d'alert ont
changé le monde en dévoilant les grands
secrets d'état est notre invité cette
semaine marielle de sarnez bonjour
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
députée européene vice présidente du
modem et celle de chef de file du modem
pour les municipales à à paris une
question vous habitez dans le 14e depuis
toujours et ce que vous en disiez un
géant mais lui dit il à fait exacts mais
parisienne on a habité dans beaucoup
d'arrondissement moi qui suis parisienne
j'habite ici selon vous voyez vraiment
vous présenter dans un autre
arrondissement la question des listes
est importante la question de l'endroit
où on se présente est important et ça
compte mais ce qui compte le plus au
fond c'est qu'est ce qu'on a envie de
faire de cette ville quels sont les
projets qu'on a envie d'avancer quelle
est la gouvernance que nous voulons pour
cette ville je porte l'idée d'un
renouvellement nécessaire on doit
renouveler la manière dont les choses se
font et se gouverne à paris on a une
gouvernance qui est trop partisane je
veux du renouvellement le renouvellement
ça n'est pas remplacé simplement une
équipe par une autre c'est changer
profondément la manière dont on gouverne
je considère que le maire de paris et
l'équipe municipale ça doit être une
équipe qui est à la disposition de
l'ensemble des parisiens quelles que
soient leurs opinions politiques 220 si
vous deviez choisir entre élus de paris
et députée européenne les deux sauf si
j'étais aux priorités des rotary bien
évidemment je choisirais la mairie de
paris si je suis une élue parmi d'autres
je continuerai à assumer mes
responsabilités
d'élu européenne de paris pour les
années qui viennent alors entendant
marielle de sarnez on va passer en revue
la ce de la semaine semaine qui commence
sur fond de cacophonie
loin de calmer les esprits
l'intervention du président de la
république sur la sphère leonarda a
suscité des réactions en ordre dispersé
le sort de la collégienne expulsé divise
la majorité
et le premier ministre tente comme il
peut de recadrer les troupes yoann l'a
officiellement bien sûr pas question une
nouvelle fois de parler de réunion de
crise mais après une semaine passée à
critiquer le gouvernement dans la sphère
léonard d'art l'ancien président de sos
racisme malek boutih donne sa version de
l'ordre du jour
bombay la tentation d'un pouvoir
politique quand il en difficulté dans
son propre camp quand les gens posent
des questions qui sont que hausse que
les électeurs de monde c'est de demander
de la discipline tout le monde en rang
d'oignons voilà en rang d'oignons
justement pour cette séance de recadrage
tout l'état major du ps sur la sellette
harlem désir ce week end il vient lui
même de contredire le chef de l'état en
estimant que la lycéenne devait rentrer
en france avec sa famille un épisode
qu'il voudrait désormais faire oublier
et aujourd'hui je les dis nous sommes
tous soudés derrière la position qui a
exprimé le président de la république
comme je les dis j'ai eu à dire ce que
j'avais à dire quand le président de la
république a pris une position eh bien
nous la soutenons le débat est clos
quelques minutes plus tard même
invitation du premier ministre plus
question d'évoquer l'émotion suscitée
par l'expulsion de la lycéenne vous êtes
bien placé pour le savoir qu'il faut de
temps en temps revenir à l'essentiel et
pas seulement en reste et comme vous
faites trop souvent sur l'émotionnel la
standing ovation réservée à jean marc
ayrault dans l'hémicycle n'avait pas
grand chose de spontané
l'ordre de serrer les rangs et de mettre
fin à la cacophonie mettra peut-être un
peu plus de temps à être entendu
la sphère léonard à la méthode de langue
c'est le zoom de la semaine
est avec nous sur ce plateau et de
synthèse pour commenter cette actualité
thomas guénolé politologue au cevipof
c'est le centre de recherches politiques
de sciences po marielle de sarnez et la
projection je m'adresse à vous très
directement la sphère leonarda nouveau
couac ou tournant du quinquennat c'est
plus qu'un couac je pense que c'est une
crise d'autorité au sommet de l'état il
y a une chose très simple à dire à nos
concitoyens c'est qu'il faut que les
lois soient respectées dans un pays et
c'est comme ça que fonctionne et doit
fonctionner l'état de droit il y a un
droit d'asile politique pour ceux qui
sont opprimés dans leur pays qui doit
absolument perdurer mais pour qu'il
perdure il faut mettre fin à l'ensemble
des abus et donc manuel valls a eu
raison dans l'attitude qui était la
sienne qui est simplement un respect de
la légalité et la réforme qu'il veut
conduire sol audois d'asile je la trouve
le départ le jeu la proue elle est très
importante il faut que les délais soient
absolument raccourci qu'on peut pas
laisser une famille attendent la plus de
cinq ans une réponse de l'état hormis
thomas guinn au lait alors est ce que
vous comprenez quelque chose vous à la
méthode de françois hollande est-ce que
son pouvoir ou son autorité sont
affaiblis alors justement pouvoir aux
autorités
l'étymologie est intéressante à cet
égard c'est à dire que la plupart des
gens emploie les termes indistinctement
alors que ça ne veut pas dire la même
chose le pouvoir c'est la possibilité
d'exercer une contrainte pour forcer
quelqu'un à faire quelque chose françois
hollande de par les institutions a le
pouvoir
l'autorité c'est vous n'avez pas besoin
d'utiliser la contrainte ou de la
standing-ovation sur ordre par exemple
qu'on a vu vous n'avez pas besoin de ça
parce que vous avez aujourd'hui on
dirait autorité naturelle ce qui est un
pléonasme et l'autorité c'est toujours
naturel ça va toujours de soi sans même
avoir les institutions quelqu'un comme
pierre mendès france avait une immense
autorités sans avoir nécessairement le
pouvoir voyez la distinction cette
autorité là françois hollande
visiblement ne l'a pas c'est toute la
différence justement
alors l'idée c'est que finalement on a
une ambiance dans la gestion du pouvoir
actuellement qui ressemble à un congrès
permanent du parti socialiste c'est très
frappant de voir à quel point finalement
les débats entre les différents courants
et pour résumer entre la gauche
sociale-démocrate et la gauche marxiste
se poursuivre au fil du temps je partage
mon pour eux cette analyse se la
question de l'autorité dont mais c'est
une vraie question et je vous rejoins
quand vous dites c'est de votre formule
entre guillemets c'est un congrès
socialiste a maintenant pour moi un
homme d'état s'il est un homme d'état
doit gouverner pour l'ensemble des
français et pas pour les intérêts de son
parti et bien évidemment on n'est
malheureusement pas on va dire dans
cette tonalité là or la france en aurait
sacrément besoin ce que c'est cela qui
inquiète un peu comme ça après dix-huit
maintenant je pensais que françois
hollande était plutôt on va dire un
social-démocrate éclairait revendiquer
sa formation ce plutôt d'être du côté
aux côtés de jacques delors et puis on a
aujourd'hui un président de la
république qui n'assume pas cette
autorité qui ne porte pas une vision et
qui n'a pas clarifié les choix
fondamentaux idéologiques de la gauche
exactement et qui n'a pas remis à jour
ce logiciel c'est le pays qui en subit
les conséquences et danton à guénolé est
ce qu'il y aura pour vous un avant et un
après leonardo qui aura des conséquences
profondes sur la majorité et sur
l'opinion pas nécessairement parce que
on est passé ces dernières années au
temps très court de l'information et
donc a priori sauf rebondissement dans
deux semaines la sphère leonarda plus
personne n'en parlera visiblement pas
d'accord il ya un problème sur et il ya
des problèmes de fond qui s'accumulent
mais
le grand le grand enjeu à mon avis en
termes de 2 quand vous dites est ce
qu'il y aura un avant et un après à mon
avis aura un avant et un après la
séquence municipal puis européenne je
suis une parenthèse là dessus on parle
beaucoup du risque front national pour
les municipales à mon avis il est
beaucoup moins élevé que le risque est
fun au niveau des européennes où là le
fn pourrait en fait si on regarde les
sondages arriver en tête et un certain
nombre de villes peut-être quelques
dizaines en fait à plus où il ya un vrai
risque électoral fn en revanche dans les
grandes villes et dans les villes
moyennes le risque est fait n'est nul
pourtant on parle beaucoup plus des
municipales que des européennes dans
l'analyse
je crois qu'il y aura un avant et un
après parce que ça a vraiment mis en
cause l'autorité du chef de l'état et
c'est un problème qu'on va retrouver
seul moyen et le long terme et et j'ai
une inquiétude pour vous rejoindre c'est
sur la question des européennes sous les
scores possibles potentiel de ce qui au
fond veulent la fin de l'europe en
france et dans l'ensemble de l'union
européenne qui peut se comprendre parce
que grave crise de confiance mais ça ça
bête l'engagement d'un du combat de ceux
qui pensent et qui savent que l'europe
est notre seul atout pour exister que
sur très court sur ce thème à tous les
deux comment vous voyez la suite du
quinquennat qu'est ce que peut faire
françois hollande il ya un vrai problème
c'est à dire que il ya une accumulation
de circonstances défavorables
il faut bien se dire que on entre on en
est à 30 ans de chômage persistant et de
crise économique et sociale persistante
donc on est dans une société de défiance
alors qu'avant vous pouvez parler de ce
site et de confiance à l'époque des
trente glorieuses tous les ingrédients
ont fait très souvent oui mais le
problème c'est que comme dans le même
temps il ya une dette publique accumulée
qui réduit les marges de manoeuvre et
oblige à une politique d'austérité ou à
la réputation la dette on est dans des
circonstances où en fait françois
hollande des langues lentement étrangler
haut niveau la marge manoeuvre politique
en attendant la croissance comme notre
attendait godeau soit il continue comme
ça et et on va continuer à avoir un
délitement un délitement en france une
vraie perte de confiance avec tous les
risques qui peuvent arriver avec soin il
réagit et pour moi réagir ça veut dire
changer de politique ça veut dire
assumer clairement une politique de
réformes dans la france a besoin alors
on continue la semaine d'abord je vous
remercie thomas guénolé d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous avez écrit ce
lit nicolas sarkozy chronique d'un
retour impossible pour l'interrogation
merci de nous avoir parlé des centres
ici voulu et bien marielle de sarnez
vous devez être au courant lui d y fête
ses un an vous le dire dans un instant à
oignies ce fameux mariage entre le deuil
et le modèle mais on a voulu aller à
l'anniversaire de lui dit c'est cécile
ci dessous qui a laissé traîner son
micro pour savoir ce qu'il pensait un
petit peu de ce mariage regarder le
mariage n'est pas encore consommée mais
ce soir au cames germignan président des
jeunes modem dans les hauts-de-seine est
venu en curieux pour rencontrer ceux qui
pourraient bientôt être les membres de
sa future famille politique j'attends de
voir justement ce qui va se passer dans
le
futur contrat de mariage qu'on nous
annonce entre notre mouvement donc le
mouvement démocrate et l'union des
démocrates et des indépendants chose qui
est que je demandé que j'attends depuis
longtemps c'est qu'on soit un centre
qu'on ait une union des centres voilà
pour les municipales surtout puis après
pour les européennes s'unir pour les
élections du côté des militants udi
aussi l'idée fait son chemin le modem
maintenant c est rentré dans une posture
qui est beaucoup plus d'opposition et de
critiques du gouvernement actuel donc à
partir de là on peut plus travailler
avec lui que lorsqu'il s'est déclarée ni
neyret c'est vraiment au milieu sans
jamais faire de ce réellement se
positionner si l'union semble bien
avancer toujours pas d'annoncé
officielle
pour jean louis borloo les deux parties
ne sont toujours pas d'accord sur les
termes du contrat en toile de fond d
alliance modem ps aux municipales
notamment à dijon le diable se cache
dans les détails
donc comme on n'est pas convoqué par la
police on attend de faire les choses
proprement mais c'était mon objectif ya
un an j'avais dit je redirai que tout le
monde voilà je pense que cet objectif
ait réussi en ce qui concerne
directement lui dit et j'espère
élargi officiellement dans la chapelle
centriste personne n'est opposé à
l'union une conférence de presse commune
devrait réunie à jean louis borloo et
françois bayrou qui ne se sont pas
retrouvés sur la même photo de famille
depuis onze ans
alors mariage de rêve au mariage d'amour
mariage absolument nécessaire
rassemblement absolument nécessaire mots
d'amour d'amitié mais c'est pas
simplement salle que ce qui compte le
plus c'est d'offrir une alternative aux
français c'est à dire de d'être une
offre nouvelle sur le champ politique
français on vient de parler de l'état du
pays on vient de parler de la crise de
confiance de la crise d'autorité on
pourrait rajouter que quand on regarde
un la désespérance des français leur
colère devant les alternances
successives depuis 30 ans qui fait que à
chaque fois on vous raconte des blagues
à chaque fois les promesses ne sont
jamais tenues etc élection après
élection on est de plus en plus déçus
quand on regarde le paysage politique
qu'est ce qu'on regarde qu'est ce qu'on
voit au parti socialiste on voit des
divisions idéologiques extrêmement
lourdes et on voit et on voit je le pose
on voit
et on voit à l'ump les tensions très
fortes et bien à tout cela nous
répondons union nous répondons
rassemblement si on veut que le centre
soit fort dans le pays si on veut qu'ils
pèsent si on veut qu'ils soient entendus
et qu'il change le paysage et la vie
politique française il faut qu'ils se
rassemblent et c'est ça que nous allons
faire ce que vous avez déjà un texte
commun nous avons un texte commun dans
lequel nous avons beaucoup travaillé
depuis quelques jours quelques semaines
et sur lequel jean louis borloo et
françois bayrou ont bien travaillé
puisque il est aujourd'hui abouti et
donc après ça va être une question de
dates deux jours dans les jours qui vont
venir car dans les jours qui vont venir
vous nous verrez vous verrez ensemble
gens nus dans l'eau françois weiten et
leurs équipes respectives pour le début
d'une offre nouvelle que nous allons
proposer au pays et c'est ça qui compte
ce qui va compter c'est pas simplement
de le faire ce rassemblement c'est qu'il
soit utile à la france et à l'europe
alors on a baladés notre micro dans les
coulisses de l'assemblée pour demander
aux parlementaires udi ce qu'il pensait
de ce mariage ils sont interrogés par
hugo leenhardt et rodolphe perron croit
que celle a perdu quelques jours en tout
cas les choses sont bien engagées elles
sont bien d'agir puisque françois bayrou
a dit clairement qu'il était dans
l'opposition gouvernement dans une
opposition constructive comme nous le
sommes donc il s'agit de bâtir
naturellement un projet d'accord
d'accord ça se rende de valeur et puis
naturellement d'avoir des partenaires
privilégiés qui sont comme chacun sait
l'ump la droite républicaine en
particulier la question est posée le
calendrier n'est pas encore complètement
arrêté puisqu'il ya une discussion sur
un contenu de charte qui effectivement
mettrait d'accord lui dit et le modem
donc voilà donc il ya des discussions
qui se font comme dans tout contrat de
mariage l'alliance entre jean louis
borloo lui dit et françois bayrou et le
modem c'est la reconstitution d'un axe
central de la vie politique et ça prend
quelques temps pour mettre en place les
conditions de cette alliance politique
pourquoi est ce que nous voulons un
socle solide parce que derrière nous
voulons être crédibles aux yeux des
français et vous savez quelquefois pour
rédiger un contrat de mariage dans un
simple couple il faut un peu de temps
aux notaires mais c'est le signe du
sérieux simplement je souhaite qu'il y
ait une clarification politique on est
dans l'opposition plan national vous
issue constructive mais une opposition
ferme des choix qui nous conduisent
droit dans le mur il faut qu'on clarifie
la position plan local peut pas être
dans l'opposition nationale et puis
accepter l'idée qu'au plan local le
modem puisse soutenir des municipalités
socialistes et participer activement au
tout le monde semble d'accord en tout
cas j'ai juste entendu la proposition
vous êtes vraiment dans l'opposition
ferme écoutez on s'oppose au
gouvernement et à ses choix est assez
non choix j'ai les mêmes dire et à son
absence de choix pour autant je suis
contente que françois sauvadet le disent
bien sûr qu'il faut que ce soit une
opposition constructive il faut que ce
soit une opposition non manichéenne on
n'est pas là pour rajouter à bord n'est
pas la droite dans la caricature après
c'est vous qui êtes libre de vos
jugements il y à des personnalités à
l'ump qui ont des jugement nuancé moi je
fais partie de ceux qui ne se critique
les choix qui sont faits par le
gouvernement mais qui ont envie que mon
pays réussissent je ne souhaite pas
l'échec de mon pays et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut une opposition qui propose et
nos positions donc intelligente
un petit peu ces voix peut-être un peu
plus discordants peut-être qu'elle
vienne haussier de l'ump qui disent cet
accord n'ira pas bien loin c'est une
annonce électoraliste pour les
municipales et surtout pour les
européennes je comprends que l'ump voilà
se posent des questions mais je pense
qu'ils ont tort parce que c'est
absolument nécessaire qu'il y ait dans
ce pays un pluralisme quand le centre
existe et quand il est fort qu'est ce
qu'ils baissent ce sont les extrêmes qui
baisse et bien sûr ce point là nous
devrions les uns et les autres me
semble-t-il nous rencontrer sur le
terrain des municipales quelle sera la
marge de manoeuvre pauline déciderons
ensemble de ce que nous faisons dans les
villes mais vous savez dans la plupart
des 36000 communes on va dire ce sont
des faits locaux dans les toutes les
petites villes de france une et maire de
dijon qu'autre chose ça mais dans les
petites villes de france les maires ont
des noms des alliances locales qui sont
d'ailleurs en général non partisane et
ils ont bien raison et puis dans les
autres grandes villes de france nous
regarderons ensemble sur marseille
regardons s'il y a par exemple une
troisième voie possible est ce qu'il
peut y avoir une liste au centre à
marseille ou dans tous les cas une
équipe du centre qui se met au travail
et qui regarde ce qu'on peut apporter
dans cette élection municipale à paris
il faut que le centre s'affirme j'essaye
de faire en sorte qu'il le fasse je pose
nous posons un certain nombre de
propositions et de contenus sur la table
je souhaite un renouvellement à paris je
souhaite qu'ils aient des rassemblements
possible aussi si je souhaite à
renouvellement ce que je considère que
voilà probablement il faut une équipe
nouvelle mais c'est pas simplement
remplacer une équipe ancien par une
nouvelle équipe qu'il faut c'est un
changement je voulais dit en profondeur
dans la manière de gouverner la ville je
note que la candidate de l'ump est une
candidate qui fait évoluer les lignes au
sein de son propre parti politique
et je trouve ça intéressant juste un mot
de 2017 vous dites que le candidat futur
du centre sera choisi par une procédure
démocratique qu'est ce que ça veut dire
même pour être exact la des candidates
où le candidat est ce que c'est une
précision absolument utile on va pas
faire de confidences mac est ce que ça
implique du primaire
si on avait voulu écrire primaire on
aurait écrit primaire nous disons le
centre aura une candidate ou un candidat
et nous disons cette candidate ou ce
candidat sera choisi par une procédure
démocratique facilité par lots peuvent
se faire mais ça laisse beaucoup de
possibilités ça nous laisse aussi la
possibilité d'innover dans ce domaine là
comme dans d'autres parce qu'il faut que
nous soyons une force de propositions
nouvelles on a besoin de construire la
france à 10 ans ou à 20 ans ça n'est pas
une affaire d'élection pour répondre sur
la question des élections c'est une
affaire de génération
alors parlons maintenant si vous voulez
bien d'économies mardi les députés ont
voté ont voté une mesure importante
l'epargne sera davantage taxées
ramener le déficit de la sécu à 12,8
milliards d'euros fin 2014 c'est le
nouveau défi du gouvernement les
boissons énergisantes seront taxés et la
fiscalité augmente et pour certains
produits d'épargné et ce rétroactivement
mesure inconstitutionnelle dit la droite
mario lefebvre
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour les 10
millions de détenteurs d'un plan
d'épargné logement les cinq millions et
demi de personnes qui possèdent un plan
d'epargne d'action et tous ceux qui ont
une assurance vie désormais les plus
values de tous ces produits d'épargné
seront taxés à 15,5 pour cette mesure
que nous prenons est une mesure d'équité
car il n'est pas normal que lorsque l'on
détient des actions directes et qu'on
les vents ont soit taxée à 15,5 et
peut-on comprendre qu'on l'ait détient
dans le cadre d'un pea on ne le soit pas
le principe d'égalité ça existe le
principe d'équité ça existe et le
principe de simplification de nos impôts
ça existe car ces plus values étaient
accès de façon variable en fonction de
l'année d'ouverture du conte et de la
date de sortie des fonds à la tribune
les députés de l'opposition se sont
succédé pour dénoncer cette nouvelle
hausse d'impôt l'insécurité juridique et
fiscal que vous développez
systématiquement des mesures
rétroactives sur malheureusement tout à
fait néfaste car la taxation sera
rétroactive et s'appliquera depuis le 26
septembre dernier l'ump crie au scandale
et estime que cette taxe est
anticonstitutionnelle le taux désormais
et dissuasif et surtout cette manoeuvre
est rétroactive c'est tout à fait
inacceptable scandaleux c'est une perte
de confiance et qui risquent de se
manifester au total cette uniformisation
par le haut des prélèvements sociaux
devraient rapporter 600 millions d'euros
dans les caisses de l'assurance maladie
marielle de sarnez est ce que pour vous
il est juste de taxer rétroactivement
certains produits aussi populaires que
le pel ou là sur nantes pas du tout la
racaille et sur ce point a absolument
raison ce dont on souffre en france ce
dont nos entreprises souffrent or c'est
elles qui créent l'emploi c'est pas
l'état qui créent les emplois sur les
entreprises c'est d'une instabilité
total juridiques financières fiscales et
bien ceci ne peut plus durer et là c'est
exactement la même chose qui se passe
avec les parcs quand vous n'êtes pas sûr
quand vous n'avez pas un cadre vous
n'investissez plus et donc il ya plus
des pagnes à plus d'investissements et
évidemment tout ceci va fragiliser plus
encore notre situation économique est
déjà catastrophique
donc je considère que c'est une mauvaise
mesure et moi je demande que françois
hollande il repense à deux fois en
particulier la taxation de tous les pel
de tous les jeunes qui avaient avec des
petits salaires fait de toutes petites
économies sur le pays a réalisé et je
trouve que mais c'est le contraire de ce
qu'on voulait offrir à notre pays c'est
à dire un espoir pour notre jeunesse et
je demande que françois hollande
revienne sur sa décision et le fait que
ce soit rétroactive ça vous choque
également et c'est très choquant c'est
sa voix voulez-vous gagner la confiance
ou stabiliser une confiance si vous vous
dites ah bah non seulement les règles
vont changer pour demain mais elles vont
changer pour hier c'est impossible et
pourtant des 600 millions d'euros
d'économies ou de 450 pour
pour notamment pour la sécurité sociale
ça va d'un bon sentiment n'injectera pas
d'un bon
sentiment il ya un moment où on ne peut
plus au four stabiliser nos dépenses ou
faire baisser notre dépense publique
sans faire des réformes et sans conduire
des réformes sérieuses en trois ans le
temps de les conduire on ne réglera pas
les problèmes de la france simplement
par des impôts supplémentaires des taxes
supplémentaires et qui plus est
justement libenter rétroactif on
rencontre avec des prélèvements ses
progrès que le rat les câbles m on
règlera les problèmes de la france en
prenant un par un les grandes questions
de la réforme par exemple de l'état de
la réforme par exemple des collectivités
locales et en allant jusqu'au bout de
réforme pour faire mieux en dépensant un
peu moins d'argent pour vous la france
donne le mauvais exemple en europe en
étant le deuxième meilleur taux 46 % du
produit intérieur brut c'est ce que
représentent les yeux bien sûr on à la
dépense publique la plus la plus haute
d'europe et on ne peut pas dire qu'on
est le meilleur système de protection
d'europe donc il ya quelque chose là qui
ne va pas et donc ce sont par des
réformes profondes qu'on doit passer et
pas par de la simple taxation que l'on
peut se passer mercredi on va parler du
droit du sol
on en parlait au début de cette émission
après laffaire leonarda c'est le débat
sur l'immigration qui est relancé le
gouvernement veut réformer le droit
d'asile ump répond réforme du droit du
sol écouter ce reportage d'anne gavalda
à la sortie du conseil des ministres
manuel valls vient expliquer en personne
sa réforme du droit dess nous avons
lancé une concertation depuis l'été
dernier pour notamment comme l'a rappelé
le président la république samedi
dernier c'était un engagement de sa
campagne accélérer les délais de gestion
du droit d'asile qui est un droit comme
vous le savez constitutionnel le
gouvernement veut à tout prix éviter
d'autres affaires leonarda la jeune
fille et sa famille ont résidé
illégalement quatre ans en france après
leur première demande d'asile on ne peut
plus accepter que comme on l'a vu à
l'occasion de cette affaire des familles
puissent rester sur le territoire
pendant quatre ans de recours en ont
recours à n'être pas fixé sur leur
propre sort la mission parlementaire
livrera ses conclusions mi novembre avec
deux objectifs raccourcir les délais de
gestion de chaque dossier en moyenne un
demandeur d'asile attend une décision un
an et demi et limiter les recours
possibles après un refus si la gauche
s'occupe donc du droit d'asile la droite
elle entend s'attaquer au droit du sol
qui permet aux enfants d'étrangers
d'obtenir automatiquement la nationalité
française à leur majorité s'ils ont
résidé un nombre d'années minimum en
france il s'agit simplement de dire que
des parents des enfants nés en france de
parents illégalement installés sur le
territoire français ne peuvent pas
devenir automatiquement français c'est
incompréhensible
après une réflexion en interne
l'opposition pourrait déposer une
proposition loi plus globale sur
l'immigration
voilà le clivage politique qui reprend
de conception de philosophie droit
d'asile droit du sol le droit du sol
c'est une philosophie fondamentale du
pacte républicain et d'ailleurs je vois
que à l'ump nombre de responsables et de
personnalités politiques l'ont exprimée
récemment et puis il faut que nous
sachions entre nous que nous avons un
droit du sol qui est relatif c'est à
dire qu'on ne devient pas français par
la naissance on devient français par le
droit du sol en étant resté un certain
nombre d'années sur le territoire en
étant resté à sa tombe d'année sur tf1
c'est important de dire les choses c'est
très important
qui veut en revanche se manger seul vous
êtes d'accord je crois qu'il faut
répondre poser les bonnes questions et
essayer d'y répondre la bonne question
c'est comment on règle comme en maîtrise
la question de l'immigration illégale et
je pense que la voie choisie par manuel
valls et la bonne c'était d'ailleurs ce
que jacques chirac disait il ya une
vingtaine d'années là où on a des abus
ce sont dans les demandes de droit
d'asile puisqu'on a à peu près
simplement 10% de ces demandes qui sont
regardés favorablement qui ont des
réponses positives par an ce qui veut
dire qu'il y a trente mille personnes à
qui nous faisons des réponses négatives
et bien moi je demande une chose c'est
qu'on n'attende pas trois ans quatre ans
cinq ans pour dire à ces familles que
leur demande de droit d'asile politique
est rejetée je trouve que jean françois
copé on va enfin on va pas personnaliser
je considère non mais je considère que
vouloir à tout prix reprendre les mêmes
mots que le front national c'est pas la
façon de le faire baisser la manière de
faire baisser le front national c'est
d'être nous-mêmes d'avoir une cohérence
d'avoir des convictions d'avoir nos
propres valeurs et au nom de ces valeurs
là d'apporter des réponses aux problèmes
le problème c'est un l'immigration
illégale donc oui réformons le droit
d'asile d'ailleurs c'est une
parlementaire centriste en particulier
valérie l'état pour laquelle j'ai
beaucoup d'estimé qui va notamment
remettre un rapport à manuel valls qui
va je le sais aller dans le très bon
sens deuxièmement je considère que nous
devons réfléchir à la manière de penser
des flux migratoires de demain pour les
réguler et qu'on doit le faire au plan
européen et pas simplement au plan
franco français voilà deux propositions
que je fais sur la table pour vous
marielle de sarnez c'est le bon moment
pour lancer ces réformes il faut aussi
qu'elle soit fait en coordination avec
l'agenda européen mais il faut qu'elle
soit fait en coordination avec l'aja
d'un européen parce que nous avons une
question de flux migratoires qui
concerne l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne j'ajoute que je suis depuis
longtemps j'ajoute que je suis aussi
depuis longtemps pour que nous ayons un
partenariat nouveau afrique union
européenne que l'afrique est demandeuse
qu'on ne regarde pas assez au fond
quelles sont les valorisations les
potentiels de croissance de ce grand
continent
oui ça peut être une opportunité
formidable pour autant qu'on la
saisissent alors question d'actualité
justement 100% européenne ce mercredi
dans l'hémicycle les députés ont
notamment interpellé le gouvernement sur
la politique migratoire de l'europe on
en parle et aussi sur l'entrée plus
spécifiquement de la roumanie et de la
bulgarie dans schengen je vous demande
solennellement comme nous l'avons fait
par le passé d'opposer un veto à
l'entrée de la bulgarie et de la
roumanie dans l'espace schengen au 1er
janvier 2014 pour ce qui concerne
schengen et vous l'avez dit mais il faut
le dire encore plus clairement ce n'est
pas une question qui concerne l'union
européenne en son sein mais évidemment
l'organisation et la surveillance des
frontières extérieures
il n'a d'ailleurs pas de décision
concernant le 1er janvier de l'année
prochaine le 1er janvier 2014 faut pas
confondre ce sujet là avec la
problématique de l'ouverture au travail
mais il s'agit tout simplement de dire
qu'aujourd'hui le ministre des affaires
étrangères a déjà eu l'occasion de le
souligner la bulgarie et la roumanie ne
sont pas prêtes pour entrer dans
schengen et le gouvernement la france a
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire alors il
ya beaucoup de confusion autour de ce
sujet en kaminis clarifier un peu vous
même en tant que députée européenne
qu'elle est votre conviction de la
france a raison de refuser l'entrée
raison de récupérer l'accès à l'espace
schengen de la roumanie et de la
bulgarie parce que quand on est dans
l'espace schengen les pays qui en sont
membres doivent assurer assumer la
surveillance des frontières extérieures
de l'union européenne avait caché
d'autres pays schengen c'est ça ça n'est
que ça et ça résonne bien évidemment
relation pas du tout on mélange deux
choses roumanie et bulgarie ne doivent
pas entrer ils ne sont pas aujourd'hui
en capacité tout le monde le sait de
surveiller efficacement leurs frontières
extérieures schengen sur la gîte le
chiffon rouge à quelques
regarder ce qui se passe à malte ou à
lampedusa là aussi c'est le problème de
la surveillance de la méditerranée et
des frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne et en particulier de l'espace
de schengen schengen fonctionnera quand
on mettra aussi un symptôme de moyens en
place moi je suis pour faire une
proposition pour mettre un certain
nombre de mettre en place des garde
côtes européen comme il ya d'ailleurs
aux états unis je fais cette proposition
depuis longtemps c'est vraiment
uniquement une question de volonté
politique des chefs d'état gouvernement
dans l'union européenne ou de la route
j2me feu stop vous dire concrètement
faisons une pause
approfondissons d'abord notre union
européenne réformons ce aucune mérite
d'être réformé avant d'élargir la
turquie non non la turquie non et
d'autres pays non moi je vous dis
faisons une pause approfondissons
l'union européenne c'est un enjeu
absolument énorme on doit recréer la
confiance entre les citoyens de l'union
européenne et le fonctionnement de
l'europe et donc oui il faut porter à
cet homme de réforme et cette aux
européens que nous sommes de porter ces
réformes alors parce que je dois parler
logement au sénat
et en plein débat parlementaire sur la
loi duflot une des mesures phares à
l'encadrement des loyers a été vivement
critiqué par le conseil d'analysé
économique c'est un organisme très
proche du gouvernement l'article
important était votée la veille de la
sortie de ce rapport il est jugé
inopérant inefficace rapport qui remet
en cause également les aides au logement
qu'est ce que vous en pensez marielle de
sarnez vous qui avez présenté cette
semaine votre plan marshall du logement
c'est à dire la production de 100 mille
logements supplémentaires l'innovation
avec des baux emphytéotiques la
couverture des gares pour la création de
vingt mille nouveaux logements
construits et leurs lèvres - de landon
ps et ump ont dit du bien et donc tant
mieux j'envoyais c'est le conseil
d'analysé économique qui a raison il
faut mettre de côté les deux
propositions qui sont un l'encadrement
de la garantie universelle locative
parce qu'on va arriver à quelque chose
de très très simple avec la loi duflot
ce qu'ils sont on va dire
et plus pauvres pour aller vite ceux qui
sont les moins aisés vont voir leurs
loyers augmenter ceux qui sont les plus
aisés vont voir leurs loyers diminuer
alors écoutez on rêve complètement bien
évidemment il faut qu'on remette et que
le gouvernement remettre l'ouvragé sur
le seul apte à proposer à la place de
cette mesure vous propose à la place
d'avoir des observatoires comme ça se
fait partout comme ça se fait en
allemagne comme ça se fait au québec
d'avoir des observatoires des prix du
loyer avec siégeant des gens qui sont
bailleurs propriétaires et que
l'observatoire rendre publics les prix
on va dire quartier par quartier pâté de
maison par pâté de maison et qu'on
renvoie quand il ya un problème qu'on
renvoie non pas immédiatement la justice
qui est déjà complètement embouteillée
mais qu'on renvoie à une gestion
prud'homale ou en tous les cas à des
médiateurs je pense que là la france
pourrait innover en s'inspirant
utilement de ce que font nos voisins je
dois vous entendre sur un point très
précis cette semaine qui a vu au sénat
en commission des affaires économiques
le projet de loi sur les retraites a été
retoqué qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous je vous comprends qu'il était en
toc et je regrette que le gouvernement
n'ait pas pris n'est pas apporter
davantage de considération à la
proposition que le groupe du centre a
fait au sénat et en particulier celle
qui a été porté par jean marie
vanlerenberghe qui reprenait ce que nous
disons et françois bayrou depuis
longtemps c'est à dire qu'on a besoin
d'une vraie réforme de fond des
retraites avec enfin la mise en place
d'un système par points et à terme et à
terme un régime unique chacun de ceux
qui ayant été dans les régimes spéciaux
gardant évidemment leurs avantages
acquis et donc là aussi le gouvernement
a loupé une occasion ça peut marcher en
france la lame et ça marchera forcément
ça se fera un jour parce que pour rendre
pour pérenniser notre système de
retraite est pour avoir un système de
retraites juste et pas tout faire
reposer sur les futures générations
c'est la seule solution tous les pays
d'europe au fond qui ont réfléchi à
cette question de la mise en oeuvre ça
prend du temps être mises en oeuvre et
c'est pour ça que je regrette vraiment
que françois hollande ne l'est pas
décider parce que ça prend non ça prend
du temps ce que c'est long à mettre en
oeuvre donc ça prend 6 ans 7 ans 8 ans
et donc on devrait d'autant plus
l'organiser et le lancer dès aujourd'hui
je propose deux parties 2 mission c'est
le plus de l'hebdo mois s'intéresser aux
lanceurs d'alert ces nouveaux héros du
nouveau monde
c'est le cinquième pouvoir wikileaks et
ses révélations ont fait l'effet d'une
bombe un film vient de sortir aux états
unis il raconte l'histoire de
l'organisation et de son fondateur
julian assange
la sortie est prévue en france le 4
décembre
un film qui fait déjà du bruit sur fond
d'affaires d' écoutes américaines si
longue barbarie
après avoir fait trembler
l'administration américaine les lanceurs
d'alertés font tousser hollywood de long
métrage le cinquième pouvoir consacré au
fondateur de wikileaks julian assange
est un échec au box-office
que chaque morceau
un
flop en partie attribuée aux plus
célèbres cybermilitants de la planète
julien assange lui même une arme de
propagande massive au service des états
unis selon lui pourtant ce film se veut
une illustration fidèles de la
trajectoire de wikileaks entre 2007 et
2010 période où l'organisation révèle
des abus commis par l'armée américaine
en irak et en afghanistan et pour
concéder ce que l'on a nommé le cabl
keith richards
le cinquième pouvoir dont les salles
françaises de 4 décembre prochain
soulève une question cruciale les
lanceurs d'alertés sont ils de dangereux
traître une des héros visionnaire à
l'heure où les révélations de l'ancien
agent de la nsa edouard snowdon continue
de jeter le trouble dans les relations
diplomatiques américaines des lanceurs
d'alert à défaut d'avoir un rôle majeur
à hollywood sont déjà des acteurs
puissants dans le cercle très fermé des
relations internationales
you may elle de sarnez pour reprendre la
question du réalisateur bill condon est
ce que les lanceurs dallaire que les
whistleblowers comme julian à saint jo
edwards snowdon sont des héros des temps
modernes de nouveaux héros oui oui
j'entends des héros j'utiliserai
peut-être pas ce mot là mais non mais
c'est très important et c'est très
intéressant en même temps et je
considère que les citoyens du monde ils
ont le droit à avoir un certain nombre à
dax et un certain nombre d'informations
à regarder ce qui se passe avec les
écoutes téléphoniques et je passe en
europe vous allez venir mais si snow day
n'était pas là est-ce que ce sujet
serait sur la table en aucun cas alors
je suis pas naïve je suppose que les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
européens connaissait déjà un certain
nombre de méthodes des américains mais
qu'au fond il s'en accommoder et bien si
ces temps-là change si l'opinion
publique ce est saisie de cela par les
lanceurs d alerte et dis-moi opinion
publique française ou européenne
je ne m'accommode pas que les américains
que j'aime par ailleurs j'aime les avec
mais que les américains viennent chez
moi comme s'il était le gendarme du
monde ou de l'europe eh bien peut-être
les choses changeront un peu tout le
monde écoute tout le monde que ce qui
lui enfin écoutez j'ai vu l'ancien chef
des services secrets français qui a dit
ça à mon avis la france soit disant
écoute les états unis je pense qu'un 1
qui écoute un peu plus que l'autre
langue fait pour la région avec ça je
parle de moi il ya tout simplement fond
le débat est lancé je trouve c'est un
bon débat et moi je dis ce sont pas des
explications qu'on doit demander aux
américains on doit mettre fin à cette
situation comment ça n'est pas pareil
quand et j'espère que le conseil
européen va avancer dans ce sens puisque
angela merkel était elle-même parce que
comme sable écouter non mais peut-être
calito téléphone opération pour vous ce
genre de situation et ça n'est pas
tenable d'ailleurs je ne sais pas en
trouver moi ce qu'ils font de toutes ces
millions de données qu'est ce que ça
leur apporte seul problème on flingue
l'exploitation d'un c'est vrai quand
même dans une vie politique assez
transparente mais il ya un principe
c'est le principe de souveraineté et moi
je crois à ça on a une souveraineté
française on a une souveraineté
européenne et donc ça n'est pas aux
américains de venir faire la police ou
gendarmes chez nous j'écris cette
semaine le taux sévère de la france
révèle plutôt du théâtre politique
plutôt qu'une réelle admiration c'est
normal tout ça c'est ils sont tous
acoquiné les uns les autres
moi en tous les cas j'ai une réelle à
digne à sion je pense que les américains
ne peuvent pas se penser par tous
légitimes sur toute la planète la
question qui se pose c'est aussi celle
de la protection des données des
citoyens roumains c'est un dossier entre
halle en europe qui tarde à avancer
concrètement
comment l'europe qu'est ce que l'europe
peut faire pour protéger ses citoyens de
l'intrusion de deux géants d'internet
comme google il faut qu'elle se décide
de le faire déjà et que nos chefs d'état
et de gouvernement décide de le faire et
décide de peser en particulier pour
l'art est et que ce faire d eau d âge et
bien évidemment les et ce dossier est
sur la table et il faut avancer ça ne
nous écoute pas remis de cette émission
avec une photo vous allez découvrir
toute cette ségolène royal les potées de
vue découvrir cette photo qui lui sur un
tapis rouge qui pousse en toque blanche
drapeau français étendard à la façon de
la liberté et le peuple célèbre tableau
de delacroix
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de cette
photo de ségolène royal où je vois
français les yeux non je ne force pas
les yeux j'hésite entre l'amusement
l'étonnement c'est assez baroque quand
même fond au courage en politique c'est
déjà c'est peut-être courageuse qu'elle
a fait qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour
vous le courage en politique le courage
en politique travaillait pour moi dire
la vérité à nos concitoyens ne pas leur
raconter des bobards tenir ce que l'on
dit et continuer mordicus de défendre
ses convictions et j'ajouterai un mot
que pour moi la fin ne doit jamais
justifié les moyens en politique qui a
le courage en politique en ce moment qui
est plus courageux pense moi j'en
connais un bien qui est françois bayrou
je pense que c'est un homme qui est très
courageux mais qui écoute et c'est
quelqu'un dont le parcours fait que on
se rend compte qu'à chaque fois qu'il
exprime quelque chose ou qu'il prend une
décision il le fait en conscience et pas
forcément pour son propre intérêt et
même plutôt l'inversé et bien c'est un
courage qui vaut pour moi admiration
ségolène royal ce qui serait courageux
impliqué aujourd'hui c'est le non cumul
des mandats tout de suite et les fusions
de départements et régions de france où
un référendum sur la moralisation de la
vie publique et si vous me demandez si
je regrette que françois hollande
n'avait pas fait je vous dis oui je le
regrette vivement est-ce qu'il est trop
tard non il n'est pas trop tard il faut
moraliser notre vie publique et les lois
qui sont en vigueur aujourd'hui ne sont
pas allés assez loin et françois
hollande devrait faire appel au
référendum pour imposer aux élus ce que
la plupart d'entre eux évidemment se
refuse à eux mêmes le courage en
politique et ailleurs en europe se
serait illustré par qui pour vous angela
merkel à laquelle franchement parce que
je vais vous dire pourquoi tout à
l'heure on disait il faut faire
attention ne faut pas courir comme ça
après le front national il faut rester
campé sur ses convictions faut avoir de
la cohérence quand on a de la cohérence
comme angela merkel eh bien on devient
un repère et quand on est un repère on
pèse et on peut faire rayonner un
certain nombre d'idées et moi je
regrette qu'il n'y ait pas assez de
cohérence dans la vie politique
française de cohérence au gouvernement
de cohérence chez le chef de l'état
c'est comme ça que l'on peut être forcée
en cohérence de courage ou la semaine
françois bayrou angela merkel oui
absolument merci beaucoup
participez à notre émission bonne
semaine katia on se retrouverait pas son
prochain dans nos bacs de ce même très
bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires merci de votre
fidélité